Speaker 1: Let's go next to where do we want
to go next? I don't know. How about Nico
from Santa Monica? You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David, how's it going? It's
going well. So I had a I had a question about I
have a question about running Democrats who are
socially conservative but fiscally liberal. OK,
I know a lot of times you say like if you run
a Bernie Sanders and Joe Manchin, Joe Manchin of
West Virginia. Right. You just got a Republican.
Right. But do you think that do you think that
you can run somebody who is kind of in line with
Bernie on maybe certain fiscal issues, who's who's
not necessarily in line with him on gun rights
or abortion rights or something like that?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think that if there is
a situation in which abortion rights
aren't really at risk and, you know,
if if Democrats control the House and it's sort
of like there's not really whatever is happening
at the state level could happen at the state
level. But federally, there's really no risk,
for example, to abortion rights. I don't really
have a problem having a Democrat in the Senate,
for example, whose personal views are that they're
against abortion. He or she is against abortion
and has some conservative social positions. If
on economics, they're going to be a strong vote
for everything from infrastructure
spending to a more equitable tax system,
et cetera, that's a trait I would make. In
other words, as opposed to a Republican,
if we have to accept that there's parts of the
country where the type of Democrat that can win
is one that is economically progressive and
socially conservative, I would accept that
as long as there's no real chance
of their socially conservative views
becoming law. And that would depend on who
controls the Senate, who controls the House
at the time. But that's the I don't I don't like
it. Those aren't my views. But I think that there
would be much to gain from having a reliable
vote on the economic issues that I would say
whatever. They're against abortion. But abortion
is just not an issue right now. Abortion rights
aren't in question. And we'll just kind of ignore
that and hope we get some good economic policy.
Speaker 2: Do you think that that
could be a blueprint for Democrats,
maybe not not not to a not to an enormous
scale, because it could compromise some of
our social values. But do you think that could
be a blueprint for Democrats taking back some
more socially conservative areas that they used
to, that they used to when not necessarily win,
but he didn't like Ike or Missouri as
Speaker 1: a strategy to take Republican seats,
if that's the only way to
do it. I'm OK with it. Yeah.
Fair enough. Thanks, David. All right, Nico from
Santa Monica, thank you very much for the call.